how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
and today we're going to be going over
and breaking down a leaked
scene from doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness now we've briefly
talked about this before
but since then it seems like we have
figured out exactly what this scene is
about
including who is in the scene and it's
actually a very important scene in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and we're going to break down
everything that we found out about the
scene
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
deadpool versus cable funko pop
just subscribe to my channel like the
video and leave a comment below to enter
so we have this dialogue for this scene
for doctor strange 2 because of a leaked
audition tape and like i said at first
it didn't quite make 100 sense but when
you dig a little bit deeper and you
connect
some of the dots it is actually quite
clear what is happening
in these scenes so the leaked audition
tape was for the role
of america chavez she's been rumored to
play a pretty significant role in the
film for a pretty long time now and now
it's pretty much confirmed with this
leaked audition tape and we're just
gonna go ahead and break it down piece
by piece
sentence by sentence not bad
can i have another one of these um what
do you call them oh oh pepperoni
no more pizza you need to tell us what's
happening
yeah but i'm hungry so to start it off
she is asking for another pepperoni
pizza but she doesn't know what
pepperoni pizza
is now this might not make sense on the
surface but since this is the role for
america chavez that means that not only
is she not a human being but she's also
not from the same universe that she is
in right now you see in the comics
america chavez hails from an alien
race and it exists in a different
dimension of the multiverse and this
actually comes from marvel's 616
timeline
so she's from a different dimension and
she's also an alien so that's why she
doesn't know what pepperoni pizza is
in the comics america chavez has two
mothers and they both sacrificed
themselves to save their world from
being destroyed by a series of black
holes they end up saving their universe
and then america chavez runs away from
home and tries to be like them
exploring the multiverse going from one
universe to another
until she ends up in this universe our
main universe talking to these two
people
in which these two people are doctor
strange and
wong if we examine the dialogue closely
we can tell that it is strange
and wong although the voice is a woman
but this is simply a woman filling in
reading the lines of doctor strange
doctor strange is actually the one that
says
no more pizza you need to tell us what's
happening and that leads us to the next
dialogue
but before we continue the breakdown
just want to say thank you for today's
video sponsor skillshare
i want to thank skillshare for
sponsoring this video and helping me
pass the time during quarantine
i know a lot of you have been asking me
about youtube how to get started
what editing software to use how to use
things like photoshop and imovie
well if you're looking for a place to
learn all of those things and expand
your creativity
skillshare is the place for you and the
great news is is that the first
thousand of my subscribers to click the
link in the description will get a two
month free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity if you're interested in
youtube you could check out classes by
the teacher sorel amore who's got great
insight on what you need
during this time of quarantine i fought
boredom off by trying to get better at
guitar by taking classes on skillshare
so for those of you who love to learn be
sure to click the link in the
description down below
and if you're not one of the first
thousand people to click the link in the
description down below
don't worry skillshare is less than ten
dollars a month with an annual
subscription just click the link down
below to get started
so the next part is actually a very
important part of this leaked scene
i don't care diamond giant demon just
took out an entire block of our city
trying to eat you
it didn't try to eat me it tried to
abduct me
why bring me a pepperoni and you'll find
out
i'll get it she's just a child exactly
i'm just a child
there you go my day thank you frank
america chavez is saying that she's
hungry trying to get more pizza but then
dr strange says
i don't care a giant demon just took out
an entire block of our city trying to
eat you
in which she replies it wasn't trying to
eat me it was trying to abduct me
now this is a really important part
because doctor strange
doesn't seemingly know what the demon is
this implies that since america chavez
is now in our universe
other beings are coming from the
universe to try and get her
because she seemingly knows why now one
of america chavez's biggest powers is
the ability to create portals through
the multiverse and it is possible for
other beings to travel through these
portals as well
so it seems like this demon since doctor
strange doesn't know who this demon
is followed america chavez and after she
says that it was trying to abduct her
doctor strain asks
why and america chavez is a teenager
she's a young
superhero so she's pretty sassy and she
says bring me a pepperoni and you'll
find out
now there's another character that says
i'll get it she's just a child and this
is going to be
wang doctor strange and wong of course
protect the sanctum together but they're
also responsible for protecting reality
particularly the reality of their own
universe when
thor came to earth doctor strange
immediately knew that he was there
same with loki because that's what
doctor strange is responsible for
protecting the universe from outsiders
and although loki and thor aren't
exactly outsiders america chavez is and
when she came a demon tried to abduct
her
so they definitely go to her in this
scene and probably take her back to the
sanctum
now wong will go on to give her the
pizza and then she says thank you frank
but this
is just for this audition they replaced
the name wong with frank
just in case this gets leaked which it
did but we see through it and this next
part is really important as pertaining
to the multiverse as well okay
so how familiar are you guys with the
multiverse
somewhat familiar just last year we
attempted to open a rift in reality
the rift in reality that must have been
an exciting adventure okay anyways let's
say
this pizza is the multiverse here's my
home reality
and over here is yours so america chavez
goes on to ask how familiar are you guys
with the multiverse and doctor strange
or wong
responds by saying somewhat familiar
just last year we attempted to open up
a rift in reality now this could be
referring to something that we haven't
seen yet or it could be referring to the
events of avengers in-game where the
avengers went back in time
using the quantum realm and the rift
that they're talking about in reality is
most
likely the 2014 thanos going to the
present time
this would absolutely mess up other
universes not to mention it messed up
their own of course
now the 2014 thanos leaving its timeline
creates a major problem for that
timeline a brand new universe
and rift have been created now they have
a timeline where thanos isn't there
or gamora or nebula so that universe is
probably definitely going
to go into madness because it's not
going to play out as it was supposed to
if the avengers didn't mess with time
but here's the most important part of
this video and
this scene they're identical in some
aspects but completely different in
others for instance you're both in
better shape where i'm from
sorry america chavez explains
the multiverse but more importantly she
explains the differences in the two
universes
and she specifically says that for
instance you're both in better shape
where i'm from now doctor strange is in
pretty decent shape but he's kind of
skinny not the buffest dude in the world
and wang isn't exactly in the best shape
so it seems like a little bit of a burn
on wong which is why she says
sorry but this does confirm that there
are alternate
versions of the characters that we know
in our main timeline
in other universes and this is very
important because
ultimately the universes will collide
and we'll see a bunch of different
versions of the same character
eventually in the mcu and perhaps we
could even see
doctor strange and wong who were both
apparently really ripped in a different
universe in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
and like we've been talking about for a
while this will ultimately lead up to
avengers secret wars battle world
an event where many different universes
collide and you have a lot of the same
character but different versions of that
character meet up with each other so
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is the setup for that it's the
setup for more than one version of a
character to appear
in the mcu so this film is really going
to kick off the multiverse specifically
jumping between
universes going throughout the
multiverse and exploring
now she finishes by talking a little bit
about her backstory
until a few weeks ago i didn't know any
of this stuff
i was just a mild-mannered orphan until
one day a
demon shows up and attacks me that was
your visual aid pointing to two
pepperonis
yeah you guys are fast planners when she
says she was a mere orphan she's most
likely talking about the fact that her
two mothers
died they died to save her universe and
now she's here in this timeline which
she most likely fled to because she got
attacked by a demon who probably
followed her which is evident because
doctor strange and wong
ran into that demon and to end it you
can kind of tell that doctor strange was
getting a little bit fed up by talking
to a teenager
he says that was your visual aid
pointing to two pepperonis and she gives
him some sass back and you can tell that
this might actually add a little bit of
comedy to the movie
but that's the breakdown of this scene
and as you can tell this scene and the
movie are going to be very important for
establishing the multiverse throughout
the mcu
so let me know what you think about this
and let me know who you think that demon
could be who dr
strange wong and america chavez run into
leave your thoughts in the comments down
below also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on anything relating to the mcu you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
for live updates and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof
you